support the production of more videos by
visiting the support move section on our
website the link is in the description
below thank you and enjoy so when we're
talking about atoms of elements there
are certain conventions that are be that
are used and so when you hear about
atoms and elements being referred to
will often see this sort of situation
here this a ZX thing what the heck is
this right the X will be the atomic
symbol of that element okay and it's
usually one or two letters either the
first letter of the name of the element
the first two letters or the first
letter and some other letter or a
similar in the in the name and sometimes
it's it's for a different language so
we'll see for hydrogen for example as
simple as H and for carbon at sea right
so let's the fittest the first letter
for chlorine it's CL right so the first
letter and then a letter that comes in a
little bit later and then for sodium
it's an A which comes from Latin natrium
okay so that's what the X represents now
a and Z are both numbers Z is the atomic
number the atomic number and the atomic
number is equal to the number of protons
in that Adam right and this is very very
very very important this atomic number
the number of protons in an element that
is what defines the element as what
defines the element okay it's very
important so if an atom of an element
has a certain number of protons that
defines the element will talk more about
what that means just a second also I've
got these little asterisks here by
atomic number that atomic number is also
equal to the number of electrons Adam
now why would that be well because
you're talking about equal and opposite
charges right atoms are electrically
neutral we mentioned that in the
previous video they are electrically
neutral
now I do want you to take care of to to
pay attention to this note it is
possible for the number of protons to
not equal the number of electrons okay
but then you don't exactly have an atom
what you have is an eye on okay which is
in layman's terms a charged atom okay
we're not gonna really talk about that
right now we'll talk about that later
okay anyway so that's what Z Z is the
atomic number okay and so for hydrogen
it is one or carbon it is six chlorine
it is 17 sodium it is 11 ok a number up
here to top left is the mass number
sometimes referred to as the atomic mass
okay what it is equal to it is equal to
the number of protons plus the number of
neutrons okay so the number of protons
that's Z right that is Z so let's write
that here that is Z and if we if we said
we could talk we could refer to the
number of neutrons as being n okay so if
we say that n is the number of neutrons
how would you find n okay well this is
basically an equation here right a
equals Z plus n ok so a equals Z plus n
and then we just solve for n right so
all for the number of neutrons so we
just subtract Z from both sides and then
we would have n is equal to a minus Z
naught B it so if we know a window Z we
can we can find the number of neutrons
okay so just to be completely thorough
here n would then equaled a which is the
mass number right minus Z which is the
atomic number so the number of neutrons
would be equal to the mass number two
mass number is the number of protons
plus the number of neutrons right and
we'd subtract the atomic number which is
the number of protons so if you think
like that number of protons minus the
number of protons wordless left with
number of neutrons equals the number of
neutrons that checks out so basically n
equals a minus Z loops let's highlight
that a little bit better n equals a
minus Z so let's put some some a's up
here at the top of these examples so for
hydrogen we're going to put one carbon
we're going to put 12 mass number for
chlorine will put 35 and for sodium 23
so we've got a's up here at the top zzz
down here and then to find n will just
take a minus Z right so the end here
would we have zero neutrons in that Adam
this Adam would have 12-6 which is six
35-17 which is 18 23-11 which is 12 so
we just found n for all of those ok now
another question that comes up is what
if I wrote Oh with 16 up here that's all
I wrote what's the atomic number do I
have enough information to answer that
question ok well earlier we said that Z
the atomic number defines the element ok
if we know what the element is always do
is look on the periodic table and if you
look on the periodic table for oxygen
its atomic number is eight oxygen has
the atomic number 80 ohs Z atomic number
is eight always if you have an atomic
number other than eight you don't have
oxygen but if you do have an atomic
number of eight you have oxygen also if
you have oxygen you know you have
exactly eight protons ok ok so this
this is very important to remember okay
another thing I want you guys to kind of
take care of a note is that I wrote this
just as Oh with 16 up here that's fine
you can do that because if you know you
have oh then you have you have to have
eight protons so you can actually save
so 16 with this oxygen here this is set
out loud as oxygen 16 and oxygen is 16
so if we had uranium uranium 238 that
would be written as you for uranium 238
being the mass number and then down here
we want the right anything but we could
write it as that same thing just copy
and paste that I might have been able
easy er to just write it whatever okay
so we'd have that and we could we could
indicate 92 down here but these are both
the same thing right because uranium
whether written explicitly or not if it
is uranium it has a Z of 92 for sure as
92 protons exactly so these are the same
thing here okay so below I've got some
questions here that we should answer
first one can the atomic number Z of a
particular element change without
changing the identity of the element
without changing the identity
development well the answer there is no
because we said that the atomic number Z
the number of protons number of protons
defines the element the number of
protons defines the element
so if you change the Z and you're
changing the element so this is not
possible second question can the atomic
symbol X of a particular element change
again without changing the identity
element again no this is kind of just a
different way right if you have if x
equals I don't know sodium na then you
have sodium if you change the X you no
longer have sodium if you change the X 2
n then you have nitrogen that's an
entirely different element so Z and X
are kind of two different
identifications right there too it's
kind of like having two ID cards it's
like a driver's license on the social
security number like they're both for
you specifically right and no one else
okay last question here can the mass
number of a particular element change
without changing the identity element
now this one the answer is yes and this
is yes so you can have a different mass
number different mass number a but have
the same Z value ok what would that mean
that would mean that you'd have a
different number of neutrons talk more
about that later if this is the case
with an element that you're talking
about you have what's called an isotope
okay isotope this is something that's
pretty important and we'll see this in
the next video so I hope that video was
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
hit with a like and subscribe for more
content also follow if University on the
different social media links in the
description below thanks and happy study